[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump's missile strike in
Syria was a stunt the heartfelt policy
changed the secrecy the element of
surprise the retaliation the
neutralization the mission itself a
stunt and much of the news media and who
knows how much of the public believe
every stupid word swallowed it like
Mother's Milk object distraction and
they fell for it
the Trump gang publicly confirmed
confirmed that the Russians were warned
in advance per the terms of a
deconfliction understanding ABC News
reports the Syrians guessed or knew far
enough in advance to move personnel and
equipment out of the targeted air force
base how the hell could that have
happened maybe the Russians told them
and while the Russians knew and the
Syrians knew to Congress know did the
American people know they didn't even
tell the State Department it was a stunt
and what do you call a stunt in which
the Americans make sure the principal
ally of the targeted nation knows in
advance that it's coming but our own
Congress and State Department do not
might that be called collusion with the
enemy it was a stunt a glorified
firework show which did nothing to
impede the Assad regime from using again
chemical weapons against its own people
it was a stunt that did nothing to
impede the Trump regime from using again
propaganda weapons against its own
people four years ago Trump sent out a
fistful of tweets about Syria condemning
exactly the stunt he just pulled in
Syria two months before Trump's stunt
he banned refugees from Syria from
coming here so the kids and the adults
who died such horrible deaths had one
less place to run to because of Donald
Trump and seven days before Trump's
stunt his government said removing Assad
wasn't the plan anymore and two days
before Trump's stunt as the children
still lay there choking to death
Trump blamed Barack Obama for it and
also two days before Trump's stunt he
cut u.s. contributions to the United
Nations Population Fund and last year
48,000 pregnant women in Syria were
reportedly able to deliver their babies
in safety because of that funding Trump
just cut so don't tell me he had some
kind of change of hearts because of the
video of those dying kids because by the
end of the year
more children may have died in Syria
because of Donald Trump than because of
Bashar al-assad and less than 24 hours
after the last of the missiles hit the
ground the Syrians were running more
missions out of that same base bombing
more people we fired what is reported to
be 94 million dollars worth of missiles
and we didn't even put a hole in the
runways and nobody noticed because
seventy nine senators publicly said this
stunt this meaningless dangerous cynical
exploitative [ __ ] stunt that didn't
even slow Assad's bombers down was a
good thing and then Trump also claimed
this was the plan in the first place the
reason you don't generally hit runways
is that they are easy and inexpensive to
quickly fix fill in and top right when
you strike air bases you never try to
destroy the runways to keep the planes
from taking off do you and the media
bought all of this one TV anchor giddily
quoted Leonard Cohen lyrics about the
beauty of the video of the missiles a TV
analyst said I think Donald Trump became
President of the United States last
night which is exactly what another
analyst on the same network said a month
earlier after Trump's speech to the
House and the Senate because every time
this idiot Trump doesn't crap his pants
or pay one of his companies another
million dollars of taxpayer money
apparently that makes them Abraham
goddamned Lincoln the retired anchor men
who will not go away and the ex generals
making TV per diem and the war
correspondent who have nothing to do if
there's no war congratulated Trump on
getting away with this one without
having an escalation of the conflict and
USA Today wrote about Trump's successful
week and asked if he would continue his
winning ways just like in the three
years after 9/11 the news media in this
country is right now suffering from a
kind of journalistic post-traumatic
stress disorder everything around them
is so outside their own experience so
different and alarming and real so
existentially threatening that none of
their cliches fit anymore and none of
their default storylines work anymore
and by god when something vaguely
familiar happens like American missiles
taking off and blowing stuff up in the
Middle East without congressional
authorization they all feel like the
tiny little world inside the beltway the
only thing simple a
for them to digest and regurgitate and
pretend they know what the hell they're
talking about
they feel like that is back that the
unique nightmare of a president who has
something wrong with his brain and tells
you he has been in office 13 weeks when
it's only been 11 he's finally pivoting
just like they predicted into an
ordinary president who just blows stuff
up and they can revert to rewriting what
they wrote in 2010 or 1996 or 1912 it
was a stunt and the media believed every
stupid word object distraction and they
fell for it I need to use a graphic to
fully explain the media at the moment
swoosh kaboom boots on the ground
Greatest Generation easy to understand
disinformation alleged collusion hacking
voter registration rolls micro-targeting
not so easy to understand and what did
those corners of the political media
miss while they fell for Trump's stunt
they missed nearly four dozen tweets
from Trump in 2013 and 2014
virtual messages in a bottle from the
Trump of Christmas past to the Trump of
Christmas present like this one again to
our very foolish leader do not attack
Syria if you do many very bad things
will happen and from that fight the u.s.
gets nothing and they also missed all of
trumps 2017 cheerleaders in the Senate
in the house in the media praising him
for this stunt when they condemned Obama
for even proposing action four years ago
Sean Hannity September 2013 glad our
arrogant president is enjoying his
taxpayer-funded golf outing after
announcing the US should take military
action against Syria and in falling for
it again much of the media missed the
real lessons of Trump's serious stunts
less than 24 hours later what was the
proton packed great America the one run
by the eternal Republican at Rollins a
man who told me to my face that I was
right that Trump is crazy
what was that PAC doing fundraising off
the children dead in Syria from sarin
gas and off Trump's stunt fund raising
up a stunt that accomplished nothing
except to make the stupid
people of this country fall for it just
like they fell for it in Iraq in 2003
and just like they'll fall for it next
time because the actual outcome of the
Syrian stunt was the chump has now
learned that whenever he can convert
true international outrage and
heartbreak into a publicity photo op
stunt he will get applause and support
and prestige and people from around the
nation willing to pretend he is a
president and not an unstable egomaniac
people willing to pretend he's a leader
and not a charlatan while in the middle
of being investigated for possible
electoral collusion with Russia decides
it's the perfect time for something that
sure looks like military collusion with
Russia by staging a phony airstrike that
saved no children delivered no message
drew no line showed no leadership
provided no hope resolved no crisis and
did not even produce potholes in the
runways resist peace